I think we've lived in every kind of
society and for a lot of our existence
as human beings we've lived in fairly
egalitarian hunter-gatherer societies
but we've also lived in very
hierarchical Turin ears as well so we
clearly can can manage to exist in both
and develop all kinds of different
societies why hierarchy seems to matter
why status differences matter so much
and so the gap between rich and poor
matters is because as human beings were
very sensitive to social relationships
you know we have an involved psychology
that makes us very aware of how others
judges if you think about it some of the
most difficult things to do or the most
potentially embarrassing situations
we're in are those where other people
can judge us negatively something rather
like what I'm doing now you know which
might go out and be seen by it by
hopefully thousands of people and they
might think I'm doing a good job or a
bad job and being aware of that I can
make us very feel very embarrassed be
very aware of how others judges and that
really affects our a psychology in our
biology and very profound ways so if
we're looking at societies where the
social distances between people are
bigger as they are in more unequal
societies there's just more potential
for all of us to feel that we're judged
negatively by others and to feel that
our status really matters that it's
really important
social evaluative threat yes that's a
term psychologists use and there are two
psychologists who looked at all the
studies that other researchers have done
on what kind of stresses most reliably
raise our cortisol levels what kind of
stress is most reliably stress us and
they usually do this kind of work by
inviting students into a laboratory and
asking them to do unpleasant tasks they
might ask them to solve math problems or
to write about an unpleasant experience
or be videotaped doing something and the
question these researchers asked work
which kind of stress is most reliably
raise our stress hormone levels and they
found it was ones which contain a social
evaluative threat so it's not so much
having to do math problems it's having
to read out your real marks at the end
and your scores and share them with
other people it's tasks in which other
people can judge you negatively that
most reliably make you feel stressed
well in our modern societies we don't
really need to consume more stuff for
basic survival we consume we shop we
want to earn more money to show our
status and so owning things that
demonstrate that you know we're keeping
up keeping up appearances and show that
we're a valued member of society that's
that's why we consume so much and in
more unequal societies that competition
for status is more important and so in
more unequal societies there is a
stronger drive towards status
competition and consumerism all of those
things matter more you know it matters
more to earn more money not because you
need more money for basic things but
because you need to sort of show your
your status relative to other people in
society